Glass Onion is a treasure Trove of
riches with secret cameos Clues even
Benoit blancmist and Easter eggs and
callbacks to the first Knives Out
including a hidden wheel of knives
yippie kai movie lovers I'm Jan and I've
been re-watching and pausing the knives
out sequel to uncover all the killer
details and things you might have missed
spoilers ahead of course so take care
when we first meet Blanc in the sequel
pause and you can spot a book called
Kane's Jawbone which is one of the
world's most complex literary Murder
Mysteries the book contains just 100
pages but they're all in the wrong order
and have to be rearranged to solve six
murders since its publication in 1930
only three people are known to have
solved it with its extreme complexity it
certainly seems like the type of puzzle
Blanc would relish solving very unlike
the mystery he eventually solves in
Glass Onion so dumb it's brilliant no
it's just dumb the books disordered
Pages might also be a nod to how the
movie reveals its story out of order
with flashbacks to different periods as
the plot on its various twists are
revealed the design on miles's puzzle
box invitation card is reminiscent of
the evil eye commonly found in Greece
and around the Mediterranean the eye can
be considered either a curse or a
protective symbol against those who'd
wish you harm and I think it's
interesting that Miles also has these
huge circular installations in all of
the guest bedrooms with the blue one in
Duke's room specifically reminding me of
the image on the invites given that
Miles kills Juke and threatens his other
friends to get them to support his
launch of clear or take Soul
responsibility for a sweatshop the eyes
on the invitation definitely feel like
more of a curse from the billionaire
than a protective symbol when the
so-called disruptors arrive on the
island miles is playing the Beatles song
Blackbird and he even claims the guitar
is the original owned by Paul McCartney
serenading me with my song on the guitar
Paul wrote it on however there's a a
clue that Miles may be lying about this
as if you go back and pause the scene
notice that he's playing a right-handed
guitar whereas Paul McCartney is
Left-Handed although McCartney did
sometimes play a right-handed guitar I
suspect this is a hint that miles is
really a phony and the guitar is a fake
as will also later discover is the case
when it comes to the origin of his
business Empire also note how he just
dumps the instrument on the sand which
is a little odd if it really is an
original Beatles guitar either way it
goes to show that miles is more
concerned with ego than authenticity you
probably noticed some of the crazy
artwork in and around miles's mansion
from the Billionaire's shirtless
portrait inspired by Fight Club a film
which starred Edward Norton alongside
Brad Pitt to the mural of Kanye West
dressed as a Roman Senator all of which
are a commentary on the type of person
miles likes to imagine himself to be but
hidden in the bathroom where Blanc and
Helen conspire are a couple of paint
meetings with some secret symbolism the
one behind Blanc is Icarus by Matisse
referring to the Greek legend the boy
who flew too close to the Sun like
Icarus who was warned that the sun would
melt the beeswax in his wings miles 2
was warned about his unstable hydrogen
technology which ends up blowing up his
mansion and melting the Mona Lisa
appropriately the body in the painting
also resembles a Chalk Outline from a
murder scene and the red heart could be
a nod to both the red square and the
Fibonacci spiral that gives away the
location of the red envelope and also
the spot on Helen's chest where she's
shot later on meanwhile the painting
behind Helen is the absence Drinker by
dagger which feels humorously fitting as
right at this moment she discovers she's
been getting drunk on Jared Leto's hard
kombucha just didn't drink this is some
funky Health stuff no you give me that
nine percent alcohol Leto's kombucha is
a fictional creation for Glass Onion but
later on you can see it's called red
planet on it referencing the name of the
actor's real-life band 30 Seconds to
Mars the glass statues which Helen and
the others end up gleefully smashing
have some hidden Easter eggs according
to Ryan Johnson this circular one
resembles the memorable wheel of knives
from the first movie and its Peg who
eventually ends up smashing that piece
when miles reveals he hired Gillian
Flynn of Gone Girl Fame to write the
plot of his murder mystery weekend it's
a shout out to the plot of Agatha
Christie's Dead Man's Folly where a
wealthy man asked the mystery novelist
to Stage a murder hunt for him and Miles
deciding to kill Duke after he tries to
blackmail him over keeping quiet about
the breaking news of Andy's death is
very similar to how in Christie's novel
The murderers kill someone who's
blackmailing them over a previous murder
and the fact that Miles mispronounces
Gillian Flynn's name I hired Jillian
Flynn to write the whole thing as in
keeping with the many malapropisms he
spouts over the weekend that's the
infraction point when Blanc and miles
are discussing the famous detective
surprise arrival on the island Blanc
says Mr Braun I've learned through
better experience an anonymous
invitation is not to be trifle with
that's a call back to the first movie
where Ransom hired Blanc anonymously in
order to try and pin the murder of his
grandfather Harlan on his nurse Martha
when Daniel Craig arrives at the pool
all covered up this feels like a
deliberate joke about his debut as James
Bond and Casino Royale and that
shirtless scene at the beach where he
emerges from the water much like
previous Bond girl Ursula Andress I
think blanc's clothing is a very
deliberate Choice especially given the
contrast with Whiskey's swimming pool
moment shortly before there's a clever
callback to the first movie in the scene
where Blanc and Helen discover Serena
Williams is available for training in
Miles private gym pause the moment here
and notice that the renowned tennis
player is Reading gravity's Rainbow the
novel that Blanc mentioned in the first
film when explaining his approach to
detective work to Martha I anticipate
the Terminus of gravity's rainbow I
haven't read it neither have I nobody is
but I like the title Ryan Johnson has
said that Agatha Christie has been a
huge influence on him and the knives out
movies so when miles spikes his own
drink with pineapple juice and passes it
to Duke this is a hat tip to the mirror
cracked where the killer adds poison to
her own glass before handing it to a
victim Angela Lansbury starred as Miss
Marple in that movie and makes a cool
cameo in Glass Onion as one of blanc's
famous friends who discovers he's the
Imposter in the game of Among Us they're
playing I saw you go in the engine room
you're the Imposter we all know it this
is a fun bit of foreshadowing for
blanc's role in Glass Onion also notice
how in the game Lansbury is suitably
named M she solved and Nod to her iconic
role as Jessica Fletcher in Murder She
Wrote composer Stephen Sondheim who also
cameos in this scene sorry Blanc they're
thrown out of the airlock it's a
no-brainer co-wrote the whodunit movie
The Last of Sheila which Ryan Johnson
pays homage to in glass onions set up
with a disruptors arrive on the dock
also in the scene is Natasha Leone who
will be starring in Johnson's upcoming
detective series poker face and former
basketball player Kareem Abdul-Jabbar is
co-author of a series of mystery novels
starring Mycroft Holmes there's another
Agatha christie-esque moment in Glass
Onion when Helen uses Jeremy renner's
hot sauce as fake blood and when miles
also uses fake blood in his murder
mystery both of which remind me of death
on the Nile where red ink is used to
fake having been shot now because like
Blanc many of us expected a densely
layered mystery and Glass Onion the
movie has fun laying out a lot of red
herrings one of the biggest of which was
the mysterious character Daryl not here
who keeps popping up saying he's not
doing anything
not here and in the end he really isn't
he's played by Noah segan who is also
Trooper Wagner in the first Knives Out
movie according to Ryan Johnson Daryl is
based on Kato Kaelin an actor who was
staying at O.J Simpson's estate on the
night of the 1994 murders and Daryl
performs a similar role in Glass Onion
Noah segan regularly appears in
Johnson's movies and in Daryl's room you
can spot an Easter egg on his surfboard
to the midnight tunnel symbol from the
director's first feature film brick
another regular Ryan Johnson cameo in
Glass Onion is Joseph Gordon-Levitt
who's the voice of miles's ridiculous
hourly dongs
you know I got full glass to compose
that Philip Glass is a famous composer
known suitably enough for his music with
repetitive structures and it's entirely
in keeping with miles's stupidity and
vanity that he would hire someone like
glass to compose something as inane as a
Gong Sound by the way Gordon Levitt has
appeared in some form in all of
Johnson's films and in the first knives
out he was the voice of the detective in
the murder mystery series that Martha's
sister was watching he crushed his skull
with a forklift and burned his hands off
to erase the fingerprint Glass Onion is
clearly set during the pandemic with
some amusing details like Birdie's Lana
Del Rey mask and Ethan Hawke's brief
Cameo credited as efficient man who
delivers a mysterious shot of something
is that some kind of disinfectant oh
you're good a nice detail is that when
Hugh Grant opens blanc's door he has a
jar of sourdough starter in his hand a
nod to the bread making craze during the
first lockdown now miles had
personalized glasses for everyone
including himself but Birdie's
long-suffering assistant Peg only gets a
generic red plastic cup but an
interesting little detail you can spot
if you pause just here is that Peg has
written her name on the cup herself not
wanting to be left out when Helen
ransacks everyone's rooms looking for
her sister's Red Envelope as she tips
out Duke's toiletries you'll see he has
three boxes of Viagra a wink to how he
infamously got banned from twitch for
selling pills that supposedly contained
Rhino horn pills which obviously didn't
work as he doesn't use them himself zero
Rhino on those pills when miles reveals
he's got hold of the real Mona Lisa he
talks about how her enigmatic smile
changes each time you view her her
Smiles there then it disappears she
happy is she sad is it something else
this might be a little stretch but this
could also be referencing the first
knives out where Harlan's portrait
changes from its serious demeanor early
on to a smiling one at the very end
after his kill has been caught and a
really nice detail is how the very final
shot of the new movie is set up with
Helen sitting perfectly poised which
feels very Mona lisa-esque The Beatles
song Glass Onion plays over the movie's
final credits and there are several
layers of meaning to this particular
song Choice similar to how the Glass
Onion sequel is purposely full of red
herrings John Lennon deliberately wrote
the lyrics to the song Glass Onion to
poke fun at anyone who'd over analyze
the meaning of famous Beatles songs so
it's full of lyrical callbacks such as
the walrus was Paul Ryan Johnson has
also revealed that there are Glass Onion
lyrics hidden in the glass artwork in
miles's mansion I spotted these glass
flowers referring to the bent back
tulips line and I think this is a hat
tip to Lady Madonna by the way Johnson
came up with the film's title when he
decided the story would be about a
billionaire living in a transparent
building then looked for a song with the
word glass in it and the Beatles track
was the first he discovered now there
are also more hidden clues that give
away the multiple twists in Glass Onion
one I missed until some of our amazing
movie lovers pointed it out on my last
video is that although Helen's made up
to look like her twin Andy there's a
subtle difference as Helen's hair pots
on the right whereas Andy's Parts on the
left and if you want to discover all the
other Clues and secret symbolism in the
movie tap here to watch my Clues you
missed video there's also a link in the
video description so what other Easter
eggs or cool details did you spotting
Glass Onion let me know in the comments
below tap here to discover all the clues
you might have missed to the movies big
twists and if you enjoyed this video do
leave a thumbs up I really appreciate it
thanks for enjoying Glass Onion with me
and hope you have a marvelous movie
living week yupikai movie lovers